Why do you do another cheek swab test and you tell us to stop certain supplements?
Should we stop right away or should we finish the bottle also how do you come up with that conclusion?
So first of all how we come up with the conclusion of the cheek swab test literally I'm prayed over your cheek swab and
Testing with kinesiology to know what is going to be the right thing to do and what to stop and what to
To continue and the dosage and all this kind of stops on testing everything on your cheek swab. It takes a while
So should you stop something right away if it says stop so yes, if it says stop just stop it
Sometimes I'll write phase off. That means just finish the bottle
And always if you have a question just call or ask a question on the zoom call
So that's what you're doing whoever asks this question. Thank you
So if it says just phase off that just just finish what you have and then you stop if it says stop then stop it
Just you don't need that anymore. You're just gonna stop left or if it says you were taking four a day and it says drop to two a day drop to two a day right away
Pretty simple instructions with that. I think that's the answer to that question